Matt Rife is continuing his journey
straight to the top of the comedy world
with the announcement of his debut
Netflix special natural selection which
will be filmed next weekend in
Washington DC during one of the 128
stops on the problematic World Tour
according to Netflix Matt Rife natural
selection will cover a wide range of
topics from Crystal chicks to social
media trolls Matt hinted that the
special will have a mix of silly and fun
content in the first half followed by
more thought-provoking material in the
second half although Matt Rife is
currently a household name in The Comedy
world with three specials under his belt
and a sold out World Tour this will be
his first major project to be released
by a large streaming platform like
Netflix the special won't be ready to
come out until later this year but Matt
is already hitting the ground running
doing the podcast circuit as he just
appeared on first date with Lauren
Compton and The Joe Rogan Experience but
there's even more podcasts in his future
because